こんにちははじめしちですはじめしちは今
ですね大阪にある不正駅の近くの商店街に
来ておりますこちら
ね結構なんか人が多くて栄えてる感じが
あってようやく人がいない瞬間で今動画
撮ってるんですけれどもこの不正紀の近く
の商店街なんと商店
街マゴホテルになってるという情報を聞き
ましたマジか
と
ホテルの中なのかもしれません商店街マゴ
ホテルってすごくないですか普通ホテルっ
てこうホテルという建物がバーンってある
イメージだと思うんですけど商店街自体が
ホテルになっている果たしてどういうこと
なのでしょうかうん普通にあの人通って
ますからね大阪に来ることは僕たくさん
あるんですけどもなかなか大阪のこういう
商店街を歩くことってあんまりなくて
すごいちょっとそそしてます結構でも
なんか栄えてるというか人がいますねと
いうわでさ速ですね今日1人で来てるん
ですけど
もあすいませ
んし今ちょっと歩いてえはいなんでおん
ねんえ君大阪の商店街あえどういうことえ
地元すよ
ここバリバリお邪魔しますはいあのサービ
も連れてきたのですごいよここ商店街丸
ホテル
マジすかうんあれもこれもどうなん
ちょっと俺もねどういう意味かわかんなく
て来ちゃったんだけど早速ちょっとホテル
チェックインしてみましょうかお願いし
ますというわけで今日は商店街丸こと
ホテルに泊まってみたいと思いますどう
いうことなのかこの俺が暴いてやり
ましょう普通におばちゃんとかおるけど
これ大丈夫かすごいすねあここがフロン
トっぽい
ですもう商店街の一角だけどこれこれが
ホテルのフロントかなここで予約する
らしいです
けど商店街の一角でしかないけどちょっと
入ってみましょう
かあ見てちゃんとホテて書いてあるあ本当
だ行きましょう
[音楽]
か
こんにちはうんホテルやな商店街だと思っ
たらホテルですね宿泊したいんですけれど
もはいお待ちしておりましたありがとう
ございます今日は職員のお手続きさせて
いただきますので僕のオレンジ色の様お
かけになってお待ちくださいはい
ありがとうござい
ますここだけ見るとマジでホテルですね外
見て
くださいめちゃ商店
街え
おしゃれ
[音楽]
それでは改めまして世界ホテルせにお越し
いただけることにありがとうございます
ありございます変わったホテルになって
おりますのでそのようですねはいホテルの
概要についてご案内をさせていただきます
はいお願いしますはい我々ですねこの商店
街を丸ことホテルに見立てた街ことホテル
と申しておりますああ街ことやっぱホテル
になってるんですねそうなんです実は商店
街のシャッターが閉まってしまったお店を
リノベーションして客室であったり
フロントにしておりまして今お越し
いただいてるフロントも看板見ていただい
たかなと思うんですがもたもた夫人福屋
さんだったところになりますはいえすご
同様にですね今商店街の中に全部で7と
客室が在をしていりますあもう商店街の
この通りがホテルの部屋になって
るってことですそうなんです商店街の中に
いたるところに展しておりますへえまた
客室が在しているだけではありません
ホテルといういればやはり気になるのが大
浴場かなと思うんですがそうですね戦闘と
いうかなんかありますよねはい私たちの大
浴場は今お伝えいただいたように先頭に
なっておりまして街の先頭がトカの大浴場
でございますすげえじゃも本当巨大な
ホテルですね朝食会場であったり夕食会場
も近隣の店舗さん居酒屋さんだったりま
モーニングを出してらっしゃるような喫茶
店に向かっていただくという形になって
ましてなるほどなるほどホテルの機能が街
の中全体に現在をしているという感で
ございます
せっかく癖の街お楽しみいただきたいなと
いうことで3つのアイテムをご用意してい
1つ目がですねこの青色のカードでござい
ます我々世界パスと呼んでいるのですが
このパスがあるだけでこの街の常連さんの
仲間入りをしていただきますパニさんに
行ったら100円おまけになったりお
寿司屋さんに行ったらドリンク1ぱい
サービスになったりそのような形でござい
ますおじゃちょっとかけときますはいお
願いします2つ目のアイテムがこちらのの
地図でございましてはい買ないぞと記載が
ございますがその待ちをご案内させて
いただいてますわかりましたちなみにあの
ペットって大丈夫ですかねあペットは
ごめんなさいあそうなんですねそっか
ごめんなさいペットではないです勝街は
全長1.8kmあるんですけれども
1.8kg350店舗ほど小さな個人点
営業されているのでもう乗せ切れてない店
がむちゃくちゃあるんですねちょっと待っ
てくださいねお店あるとグルデンフリーの
お店がありますありますマジすかちょっと
待って本当にテンション上がりましたすい
ませんあの今年小麦が食べれなくてですね
結構大阪といえばやっぱりそのお好み焼き
とかたこ焼きっていうイメージがあって
ちょっと悲しい気持ちできちゃったんです
けどすごい今幸せになりました良かった
ですこのを使ったスイーツだったりあと
ワッフルもされてますあ助かりますも絶対
食べに行きますはいでは最後3つ目で
ございます伏の街をお楽しみいただく
合言葉を定めておりましてはいそれが
ケーキ欲以降でございます景気欲降はい
はいこもですねこのかきなる様子もお
楽しみいただければと思っておりまして
この旅の景気付けに最後にオリジナルのお
みくをご用意しておりますので是非挑戦し
ていただけないかなと思っておりますあ
もうぜひぜひ行きますねはい行き
ますやばいはさん何でしたこれ数字じゃ
ないぞマジでえなんす
か見えるかなこれ十字だねいやキリスト教
ちゃいますや
んすいま10番出ましたはい10番です
ありがとうございますペットの預かり所と
かないのかないやいや俺ペットちゃいます
番のおみでございますどうぞお確かめ
ください見てみましょう
かえすごい
ぞ大々大吉すご大々大吉大吉超えとるな和
のあるうい時代遅れで肉料理をパニク料理
なら食べれそうだねあコロッケはちょっと
厳しいかな隠れロジがホトスポットええホ
スポットとかもあるんだ行きたいっすねね
ホテレにホトスポットあるのすごいな
ありがとうございますはいいかがでしたか
馬肉料理食べに行ってみますいいですね
大大大吉でとってもさのスタート切って
いただきまして衝的なさすがですではめて
なければお部屋の方まで案内させて
いただきますはいありがとうございます
よろしくお願いしますお願いしますはい
えっとですねえグネクリーンのお店が17
時までらしいですけどもうすぐ17時なの
でちょ間に合うかどうか際どいんですけど
も迎いたいと思いますはい行き
ましょうまホテルってこだもんねお風呂は
行こうお風呂行き
ましょう賑やかだねはいホテル内チャリで
走ってる人おる
なあちゃんとローソもありますねあります
ご安心くださいやっぱホテルには
コンビニ1個ついてるイメージがあるから
間に合うか際どい
なえ安くねあすいません間違ました行き
ましょう安いです
ね確かに安いないや俺は安くないすごい
ロジラみたいな道に入りましたねなんです
けど浅草通りが
浅草本当
だここか
なめっちゃ
可愛いこれ逆逆え本当です
か大丈夫みたいです
おおい行き
ましょう
可愛いこれがコミカリノベーションされた
お店ですねそうなん
[音楽]
ですえオレンジの近くにも欲しいグルテン
フリーのお店あるっちゃあるけど
めちゃくちゃあるわけじゃないじゃんそっ
すね貴重だよな本当は
ね商店街丸ホテルってことなんでいろんな
お店行きたいんですけど本当に限られて
ましてそれでもこうやってちゃんとね
グルテンフリーのお店があることに感動
するねそうすね本当にそうだってロキさん
とか見た時俺も普通に暴れちぎりそうだっ
たからね一番近くにいる人殴りそうになっ
たいや俺や
んまし
た殴りベリ
ですうわありがとうございます本当に
助かる
じゃあいただきますカメコのワッフル多分
食べたことないかもありがとうございます
ちょっといただきますいただき
ますうまうまこれが食べていいんだったら
小麦禁はマジで
[音楽]
余裕
うまかっ
[音楽]
たコメコチーズケーキも買いました良かっ
たね食べれるものがあって本当にじゃ
チェックインお願いしますチェックイン
忘れてダシでこのきたからねようやく
ホテルの大家に行きたいと思いますはい
それでお待たせしましたではこちらが今回
の客室島でございまして商店街の中見て
もう商店街の中
にお部屋ですげていただくと
はい
屋だたでございます屋
さんお待せしました
ますめっきれなんだ
けどすごいよなかあ
すご失礼し
ますえめっちゃ綺麗上行っちゃっていい
ですかはいもちろんです失礼しますすごい
すごい
[音楽]
ええこれどういうことなめちゃくちゃ
ベッドがあるぞこちら今回6人用の1番
大きなお部屋になってい
ます
すごすごいぞいやめちゃくちゃやばいなえ
待って女呼び放題かええすごい
すごいすごいよすげえ商店街の中にこんな
のがあるのかあでも確かに天井とか見ると
やっぱりなんか昔の建物感がそうですね
もう針そのままなので昔のこう大さんの
メモ書きのようなものも残ってますへえ
もう1つあの目玉がありまして目玉
はい一のホテルさんですとオシャンビュー
なんて言われるかなと思うんですがどかは
商店街に泊まれる街ことホテルですので
はい見えるのは商店街でございます商店
ビュー
はいうわ部からのですね商店街が
すげえ
すげえすごいですねそうですねなので朝は
本当にシャッターが開く音とかが聞こえて
くると思いますなるほどそれが朝の目覚め
ということですねアームのりですかね見て
さこれ皆さん隠されてるけどちゃんと電子
レンジとかゴミ箱とか冷蔵庫ホテルに必要
なものはしっかり置いてありますこれが
あれですねはいお風呂に行く時のセットと
いうことですねすげえ
わ今日ここで編集頑張ろう
よというわけでえ夕方になったので銭湯
行きたいと思いますこれもね商店街ホテル
ならではです
ねマジかっこいいよねここいや超そられ
るっすねそしてすごいのがこっちも
ちゃんとなんかね1人暮らしのお部屋
みたいトイレもついて
て先行きたくないよって人にはこっちに
ちゃんとお風呂もありますサケサ麺サ麺
じゃあ行きましょうはいこちらですまだき
でお用いてらっしゃる先さんですてえ
かなりお湯厚めですので体はパカパカに
なっていただけるんじゃないかなと思
ありがとうございますなんかすごい不思議
な感覚だねホテルにいるって思ってない
もん俺おじでございますて
エジはいっぽいんじゃないですかあんまり
関西の方以外は馴染みがないかもしれない
んですけど商売繁盛の神様恵比寿様で
ございますああでも結構聞いたことある
ありがとうございますはいでは参り
ましょうマもすごいおすすめでサウナはい
チームサウナも入っていただけるんですが
なんと110°まで上がる高温のドラ式
サウナがあります
110°意外と隠れた名サウナ
施設それは重きが深いこちらがはいお待た
せしましたでどちらがの大のイさんって
ますすごトカというのがまさにホテルって
感じです
[音楽]
ね可愛いね可愛いっすね
めっちゃ
えあれいやそんな顔長くないっす入ってみ
ましょうかはい失礼します今めちゃ
よ
め昔ならではの感じ下たがなくしたら
800円えっと2人で1600円ですええ
え何いらっしゃいまいや俺じゃねえどう
見え間違えたじゃ入りましょうかはいそれ
は何番にしよっか
な882番でいきますすごいね箱もすごい
なんか可愛い
[音楽]
ちょっと現代人の足は入らないみたいです
で昔の人と足小さかったんだろうねあ
なんかぽいっすよね大きくなったっていう
よねはい
えありがとうございましたあ斜にしたら
入る
[音楽]
これでなんと
か
効果ハイブラの靴そんな扱いし初めて
見す入りました
こんにちはあはい常連です
はい会計最後ねもなんかそのラに含まれて
えマジですかえ本当ですかありがとう
ございますえマジかそっかホテルったもん
なえじゃあ行ってき
[音楽]
ます行きましょう
か
うわやべ激やっ
[音楽]
たすごくねめっちゃ
すごいだめでし
[音楽]
た
はい入ってきました良かったね
めちゃくちゃ良かったです動画には映せて
ないんですけどサウナ入ったんですけど
めっちゃ良かったね110°激サウナに
あのお風呂も熱々でもうばっちりガまれ
まし
たお風呂さんで買ったどデカみ飲み
ますあ
こんにちは頑張ってくだあありがとう
ござい
[音楽]
ますありがとうございましたダメすよあ
ごめんなさいいただき
ます
[音楽]
あめっちゃ決まってるはいというわけでお
風呂にも入ってサ飯ですねすごいよ見
てもうだいぶ飲み屋みたいになってきて
ます小麦コ禁止なので食べれるものが
かなり限られてるんだよなはめちゃくちゃ
グルムたくさあるので楽しんでいきも
ございますのではいありがとうございます
助かりますちょっとピンク色のネオンが
光っているんですなんかエロいエロいです
ねねえちょっとこう夜の街じゃないですが
街になってまりますなるほど
YouTuberYouTuberですえ
初め長ありがとうございますなんか
すごいはい
いいピンピンだっ
てまるまるピンなんだと思うこれはうん
え何でしょうかね新品とかす
かですねはいちらってお伝えしたんですが
これがストリップちゃあこれがストリップ
ケでしはいほらシって書いてある本当だ
ご飯ここでいいはいここにしましょうこれ
はまた後でのお楽しみにしていただいて
そうですねあの撮影外で行ってきますね
はい日おすめがこちらですめっちゃ
いいさん肉のお店でございます行き
ましょうかちょっとてみます
はいすごいマジでロジラって感じになって
き
たこのホテルすごいぞ無限だぞこれ多分
ホテルの施設を全部楽しむイコール商店街
全制覇ってことでしょはいよし行くぞさ
はいうわ緊張するもうえ緊張し
ちゃう
邪し
ます邪魔し
ますあありがとうございますお疲れ様
[音楽]
ですす
ませちょっと下情報で聞いた僕ら同級生
みたい31の台ですか年です鳥ですあれよ
1年早生まれそうですそうです早生まれで
92の台そうです9ですそんな半年違う
だけでそんなが違う
ん卵のをね甘く味た結構ね味しっかりて
ちょっとあ
ますあ発
た
みたい団子みたいななんかそんな表現さ
れる
うわありがとうございます同じお醤油2個
ずつ使っ
てありがとうございますあございますご飯
なんで写真てもいいですもう
ぜひ喜び
ますでめちゃわせてますねえです
ぜひございあますしますこれあの人会計
士人会計士な寿司来ましたいただきます
いただきます後ろ
ちょっと
うま最高届いまだでも米食べるだけ
ね米と肉があれば外となんと
か遣けたえありごますこれ取り分けをにう
てくださいはいありがとうございますう
ですか
[音楽]
うわ撮影今今出し巻きの
番かわかんいただきます2発3日3日目は
あのチェックアウトしてお昼ご飯食べて
帰っいや2お客さんあ近所のミス好きな宮
ちゃ結構有名
なよろしくお願いします時代れとれです
東大阪町ですはい願お願いします男
めっちゃ男前男前です
店長ってます
てカットでの商店街のいいとてどこです
[音楽]
街を見てるんでその前世っていうか僕らの
時はまだ全然端から端まで1番あったんで
うんもうそれを見たら今はもうクっと
落ち込んであと人身があるしねうんいや
もうここ来てそれはすごい感久しやすさも
あるっていうところで
です完全にファンで
あろうこれでめちゃくちゃファンムーブ
できたこれでファンちゃうかっ
た
ははいすいませんありがとうやめて
ます1
年生活よく見てくれ
てありがとう頑張るねよく
てかったありがとうね学校で広めておくん
だ
よもよろしくな俺もよろしくなあみここの
子こいつの名前
わかる
おい長ごち様でしたどうもありがとう
ございますごち様ですありがとうござい
ましたありがとうございありご次どこ行く
んでしたっけ次せっかくお肉だったので次
は線のきましょ
てようまし丈
かホテルどこれ本にホテルか
[音楽]
ここいです
ねこおおいいっすね何を思うあのやっぱ
こちかめって感じっすね全然逆方向はいと
いうわけで次はこちらの飲み食いところ
居酒屋えっとつつぶさですかねこれ何です
かこれですふさ額が出てますいやいやいや
俺の方が上なんかねもうサーベと俺はお酒
めちゃくちゃ弱いんで多分本当記憶ないん
ですけども今おそらく記憶あるいやな
いっすもう僕誰すかかうん記憶ないんです
けどもせっかくなのでこんだけ色んなお店
がホテルの中商店街の中にあるんだったら
回線食べようということで回線と食べて
飛んでいきたいと思いますよ行き
[音楽]
ましょうどう違う違う違う違う
えここっちかこっちか学校
でみなで
し入
きまし
た食べよめちゃくちゃ
赤いとかめっちゃ
[音楽]
赤いいきます
ますめびっくりし
[音楽]
たとで今ホテルに戻って
ます飲んだなはい結構飲みましたはいもう
誰も商店街は夜なのでいなくなりましたが
こういう誰もいない商店街もいい雰囲気
ですねはいなんて人形の暑い街なんだ
ほんまに優しすぎる優しいちょっとね色々
食べ物我慢したんですけど次また来ような
はい期たいですでではバチバチに小麦粉
食べたいと思いますじゃあホテル戻り
ましょう
[音楽]
あ